Are you thankful for the Celebrate Recovery worship team?
Amen. Amen. Thank you guys.
Uh, they are so good
and they're not used to Sunday mornings,
and so some of them had some anxiety this morning.
I was real proud that they just, they they did a great job.
And so, I'm Phil Lee.
I'm the minister of Discipleship and community here,
and I wanna thank Pastor John
and our elder council for giving me the
opportunity to preach this morning.
And we're gonna be looking at the work of God
through the ministry of a prophet named Samuel.
And so please turn in your Bible to Samuel nine.
We'll be looking at chapters nine and 10 today.
And while you're turning there,
I've got, uh, some questions.
I think that personal reflection is important for us.
The kind of the why me questions.
How did I get to where I am now?
And am I where God wants me to be?
Uh, what if I had chosen something different?
And so questions of meaning
and fulfillment creep in sometimes
it's usually when I'm doing something that I, that
that's just never finished, uh, like mowing
or, um, uh, house cleaning.
And my wife is rolling her eyes now
because, uh, she's thinking,
I don't remember ever seeing you do that, or traffic.
And in Edmond, I think this is a, a kind
of a bone to pick for a minute.
Um, uh, if you're cleaning up somebody else's mess,
that's an opportunity for self-reflection sometimes.
But, but I'm gonna, I'm gonna get personal for a minute.
How many of you have ever questioned your identity waiting
in the school pickup line?
Anyone? Anyone? Yeah. Yeah. I'm just a grandpa.
And so I just get called in emergency situations
and I'm already like, oh, are you kidding me?
Why are these people waiting at lunch
to pick up their kids at three?
But anyway, um, and then there's the whole traffic issue.
It's the only time I'm ever in a hurry,
Edmund Stoplights mock me.
And, uh, the absence
of the left turn lane sometimes smirk at me.
And so, uh, but questions
of personal reflection are important.
Today I'm gonna filter into the talk, an opportunity
to tell you a story about a little boy.
He was born and raised in a tiny rural farm
community in western Oklahoma.
This is not me, but I, I got to go
to my grandparents every year,
and I, I remember filling my days with fishing and,
and I, I, they didn't let me have a
gun, so I didn't do any hunting.
But, um, I remember catching grasshoppers,
and when I caught the right size grasshopper, I thought, oh,
I'm gonna catch something with this.
And sure enough, I would learn to bait my hook and cast
and sometimes catch something.
And so that's exactly what happened to him.
And it seems as if in a small western rural farm community,
if that's the only thing to do, I've learned
that fishing is another great opportunity
for personal reflection.
And sometimes questions of meaning
and fulfillment are not a laughing matter.
You ever feel like you're just going through the motions
or you ask yourself, what's the point?
Nothing I do seems to matter.
You ever wonder if anybody would notice if you were gone?
Or do you think maybe I'm just wasting space
or just going through life one step at a time?
Do you worry that you're not making a contribution
or bringing any value?
Do you battle feelings of insignificance or doubt
or just general restlessness?
Well, these questions of significance get much darker.
If you think sometimes people will do things
to numb those feelings of meaninglessness
and insignificance, sometimes they'll numb them
with dangerous behaviors.
And I'm not gonna identify
what those dangerous behaviors are.
You know what they are.
And sometimes we flirt with those dangerous behaviors.
And some of you may be flirting with them right now,
but I'm glad you're here
because if you'll give me 25 more minutes,
we will learn about things about God
that are absolutely gonna change your perspective.
And as the scripture says, renew your mind.
These two chapters are about God at work
and the life of a man named Saul
and of his chosen people, Israel, through the prophet Samuel
and the apostle Paul, who by the way,
was a rib rabbinically trained Pharisee,
whose parents named him after a king named Saul.
Summarize the work of God in Acts 13.
You don't have to turn there,
but it says the God of this people.
Israel chose our fathers
and made the people great
during their stay in the land of Egypt.
So we see up, he made their name great in the land of Egypt
for 200 years, they were slaves.
That's good, that's bad.
And with an upli lifted hand, he led them out of it.
That's good. And for about 40 years,
he put up with them in the wilderness.
That's bad. And then
after destroying seven nations in
the land of Canaan, that's good.
He gave them the land as an inheritance. That's good.
And this all took about 450 years.
And after that, he gave them judges.
That's bad until Samuel, the prophet. That's good.
And then he asked for, and then they asked for a king.
That's bad. Yeah, that's bad. And God warned them.
This is not part of your passage here,
but God warned 'em, this is not going to go well for you.
But he gave them Saul, son of Kish, a man of the tribe
of Benjamin for 40 years.
And so last week, pastor John did a great job,
an excellent exposition of chapter eight, where Israel asked
for a king, uh, the beginnings of the mark of Israel now
as a monarchy.
And we see the transition from, uh, uh,
from where they were.
I believe it was called a tribal confederacy,
now to a monarchy.
And Samuel was getting very old.
Uh, why is it every time they asked me
to preach the passages about someone old,
he pointed his sons as judges, and they blew it.
They had become a nightmare.
Uh, they had become selfish and immoral
and unjust, not
what you want in a judge, a living nightmare.
And these people had remembered Eli's son,
if you remember Hockney
and Phineas, they didn't want anything to do with a a,
a holy man's sons or evil sons.
And so they asked Samuel to appoint a king.
And, and as I was studying for this passage, uh, I'm,
I'm reading through the scriptures
and I read in Isaiah 43, I want you to listen to this,
but now, thus says the Lord.
So who's speaking, Lord God, who created you?
Oh, Jacob, who formed you? Oh, Israel, look at verse 15.
I am the Lord, your holy one, the creator of Israel,
your king.
So when asking for a king, Israel's literally rejecting God
as their king, and they wanna be like the other nations,
but God is sovereign.
And he warned them, if you do this, it will go badly.
And indeed it does go badly.
But, but what you're gonna see as we go through first
and second Samuel, is there's up
and down points in the life of King Saul,
but God let them have their way.
And Saul, the son of Kish, has chosen
to be Israel's first king.
Well, this little boy who grew up hunting
and fishing one day gave his life to Jesus,
a little Baptist church in western Oklahoma.
And he seemed to sense God's calling
to serve him in the gospel ministry,
but he also grew very strong and very large,
and became a football star in that tiny little town.
And the University of Kansas offered him a
scholarship to play football.
So he had kind of a crisis of identity and belief
and decided, you know what?
I think since I surrendered my life to the Lord,
I'm gonna become a student minister instead
in a small town in Oklahoma.
And, uh, I was a youth minister in Tulsa, in Oklahoma.
And I want you to know right now,
if I'd been given an opportunity to play Kansas football,
I would've taken it right?
Because that's kind of a big deal.
Now you're a scholarshiped athlete,
but he has decided that he's going
to do something differently, that he's gonna not do what
looks like everybody thinks ought to be done,
but he's gonna do what God's called him to do.
Well now in, uh, Samuel one
and two, we're gonna see in chapter nine that Samuel
acquired a king.
Write that down. They acquired a king.
And I wanna talk to you about,
about confusing distractions for a minute.
There's a, uh, verses one
and two are kind of a microcosm of chapters nine and 10,
but it'll show you how we'll be looking at these in
two entire chapters.
Let's read. There was a man of Benjamin whose name was Kish,
son of Abiel, son of,
or son of Becca Roth, son of Aya, uh, Benjamin Knight,
a man of wealth.
Now, this is an important verse,
but if you're not looking for it, you don't see it.
Verse two. And this verse just frankly kind of makes me mad.
He had a son whose name was Saul, a handsome young man.
There was not a man among the people, more handsome than he
from the shoulders upward.
He was taller than any of the people.
So I wanna talk about confusing distractions, okay?
If you are not looking verse one doesn't seem
that important, but this is about a man of Benjamin
whose name was Kish, a Benjamin Knight, a man of wealth.
It's important because if we're not looking for it,
we'll forget the fact that Saul was a Benjaminite.
This is about 825 years in between Genesis 49
in first Samuel nine.
And if you'll remember back, God made a promise to Abraham
and Sarah saying that you'll be, uh, the, the beginnings
of a family that will produce a king.
And then Jacob, Abraham's grandson, he's near death
and he calls together his 12 sons,
and he blesses each of them in birth order.
And these blessings, if you will,
are actual prophecies about their future.
And Jacob's 12 sons then become the patriarchs
of the 12 tribes of Israel.
So Saul is a man of Benjamin from the tribe of Benjamin.
So when Jacob addresses his fourth son,
it's not Benjamin, it's Judah.
And he says in Genesis four, uh, 49 10, the scepter
meaning the kings, the scepter shall not depart from Judah.
Now, those of you who are, uh, familiar with scripture,
and you followed God's covenant promise all the way through
to the New Testament, you'll realize,
and by the way, Jewish scholars, Catholic scholars agree
with Christian scholars that this is a messianic prophecy
that God's king will come from the tribe of Judah.
You've heard of the lion of Judah, right?
Jesus is the king of kings
and the lion from the tribe of Judah.
Amen? Now, this is a prophecy saying
that Jesus will establish an everlasting kingdom.
And he was born about 2000 years after Jacob died.
But, but you can trace his ancestry back to Judah,
both in Luke three and in Matthew one.
But here's an essential fact
that if you're not looking for it, you'll miss.
Saul is not from the tribe of Judah.
Now, the tribal leaders, they don't know about God's
promises, yet they've not followed God's covenant still
very, very early on.
So we can't blame them for missing this covenant promise.
But we know that God intended to fulfill this covenant
of promise to Abraham, and through Jacob,
and through the tribe of Judah, a king will come
through the tribe of Judah
and will fulfill the promise of the lion of Judah
and the lion of David.
But right now, the timing isn't right.
In one Samuel, God will fulfill his promise
in his way and in his time.
But what he's got right now is a really tall, good looking,
wealthy benge of mine.
Okay? So Saul, according to verse two, was tall and wealthy.
Now, you might think, oh, this is, this is important.
Write this down. Well, this is just a minor fact.
In fact, he's one of the only Israelites identified
as someone being very tall, being wealthy and tall
and handsome, like all the kings
of the other nations is important to the Israelites,
but it's not that important to God.
But because he was so wealthy
and good looking, the people imagined him
to be the king that they wanted.
And so God allowed Saul to be king,
but this wasn't the kind of king that God had promised
and God had planned.
He wasn't unique from other kings.
He was like the na, the kings of the other nations.
And so even if it wasn't perfect, God would continue
to work through this choice.
Now, listen, wisdom is
ignoring confusing distraction
and focusing on God's promises.
And with that, I wanna talk about lost donkeys for a minute.
Okay? So the story starts off with Saul
and an unnamed service on a mission sent by his father
to find some lost donkeys.
Verse three. Now the donkeys of Kish
Saul's father were lost.
So the king said to his son,
or I mean, Kish said to his son, take one of the young men
with you and arise and go and look for the donkeys.
So it seems like maybe a little boy catching
grasshoppers to go fishing.
I mean, it doesn't seem like that big of a deal, right?
But listen, there's a literary motif,
a pattern all through one Samuel, where Saul proves
to not be a good shepherd.
And he's a, a lousy guy, probably as a wealthy young man,
had never had an opportunity to search for lost donkeys.
But this is a pattern that Saul's not a good shepherd.
And in contrast, the scripture describes David
Saul's replacement from the line of Judah
as God's plan for Israel's king as an excellent shepherd.
His leadership, his strength is dependence on God,
all examples of being a good shepherd.
So King David from the tribe of Judah gives us a huge hint
as far as what you want in a king.
And that's what he says in Psalms 23.
Most of us can quote it, the Lord
is my shepherd, I shall not want.
So David acknowledges that his strength,
strength comes from the Lord.
And then even a better contrast than that,
we find in John 10 when Jesus himself is speaking
and he says, I am the good shepherd.
I know my own and my own know me
just as the Father knows me, and I know the Father,
and I lay down my life for my sheep.
Now, I want to talk about shepherding.
Well, for a minute, you guys know I'm the pastor
of discipleship and community,
and you know that my, my role here is to help the church
to identify a disciple making church, a culture
and a disciple.
Making culture is not a good culture if it's not a
shepherd culture or a good shepherd culture.
Um, and,
and I probably am not gonna say anything more important than
what I'm about to say right now.
If you are not involved in a disciple making relationship,
if you're not being shepherded, well,
you are in spiritual danger.
As a matter of fact, if you're here
and you're not involved in a disciple making relationship,
odds are that you'll not be here in two years.
There's no real connection, there's no real guiding
or protecting, and you'll move on
because you won't think this is a good place for you.
But, but I want you to know we have 65 community groups each
with 65 plus leaders
all working at shepherding.
Well, what does a good shepherd do?
Well, it watches out for dangerous enemies that might attack
or, and it, it, a good shepherd protects and defends and,
and tends to the sick and to the wound
and a good shepherd searches
and rescues the loss or trapped.
Um, we have 65 community groups,
but we also have in the neighborhood of 30 micro groups.
Now, these are gender-based groups
that go deeper relationally
and ask questions of accountabilities
like, how are you doing?
Are you, have you been staying in God's word?
How can I pray for you? And then they do pray
for one another, and they go deeper and deeper and deeper.
And something that I'm very, very excited about is
that next Sunday at five o'clock,
we'll be launching our mentor ministry, both men and women.
And if you don't have someone who shepherds you well,
who loves you and encourages you, who you learn to trust
and to follow someone who, uh, leads and guides
and feeds the sheep, if you don't have someone,
you're in spiritual danger.
And the good shepherd loves the sheep
and tries to earn the trust of the mentor.
And so at the end of the service, if you go right across
to the, to the cross, you'll see two bistro tables
and a sign that says, men's and women's ministering.
I'd like for you to get involved in that
because true followers of the good shepherd,
love and trust the shepherd above all others.
And I pray that you have a relationship
with the good shepherd, Jesus Christ.
I pray that you're involved in
the disciple making relationship.
Do you know the Good Shepherd?
Well, Saul couldn't find the lost donkeys,
and he's ready to quit and go home.
And then an unnamed servant suggests
that they go visit the man of God in a nearby town
to see if he could help.
And Saul's like, well, we don't have any bread to give him.
And so he's got excuses why he doesn't wanna meet
this man of God.
And so, uh, in fact, throughout this, uh, story,
you see the servant being the wise one,
and not Saul, look at verse six.
But he, this is Saul's servant said to him, behold,
there's a man of God in this city,
and he's a man who's held in honor,
and all that he says comes true.
So let's go there
and perhaps he can tell us the way we, he we should go.
And so the man turned out to be Samuel, the prophet,
and this was a divine surprise appointment.
See, God, uh, Samuel, uh, was, had been warned the day
before that Saul was coming.
So you see God arranging this surprise divine appointment.
But you see Saul saying,
I don't know if we should go or not.
And dad's probably worried about us. We should get back.
Verse 16. Now, the day
before Saul came, the Lord had revealed to Samuel,
tomorrow about this time, I will send you
to a man from the land of Benjamin.
He knows who this is.
Saul doesn't know who this is, but God knows who this is.
And now he's selling Samuel,
you shall anoint him to be Prince.
Now, the the Hebrew word for prince, there is a unique word.
It can also mean ruler and leader, but this ruler
and leader is to be over my people Israel.
He shall save my people from the hand of the Philistines.
Very key phrase for I have seen my people
because their cry has come to me.
I wanna talk about clear direction.
Now in contrast to confusing, confusing distractions,
the God who sees one of the earliest names of God is El Roy,
which means he, the God who sees,
also hears the cries of his people.
And so Samuel is ready to anoint Saul
as Israel's first leader.
And then Saul and Samuel finally
meets Saul, doesn't recognize him.
Is anybody surprised?
And Samuel tells Saul,
don't worry about the donkeys they've been found.
This is really not about the donkeys. Okay?
And then he surprises Saul
and he treats him like a future king.
He invites him to a banquet
and he gives him the best part of the sacrifice.
And then he invites him to sleep there,
and he gives him the best place to stay on the roof
where the evening breeze.
And then he personally escorts Saul
and his servant to the edge of town,
which not doesn't happen to a lot of people with Samuel.
And so look at verse 27, as they were going to the outskirts
of the city, Samuel says to Saul, tell the servant
to pass on before us.
And when he'd passed on, stop here for yourself for a while,
and this is another key verse that I may make known to you.
The word of God.
This is where the clear direction comes from.
The God who sees Elroy hears the Christ his people,
and then makes known to them the word of God.
Then Samuel secretly anoints Saul with oil the next day
and officially marks him as Israel's chosen leaders.
So let's look at verse. I mean, uh, chapter 10, God
anoints a king, chapter 10, verse one.
Then Samuel took a flask of oil and poured it on his head
and kissed him and said, has not the Lord anointed you
to be prince leader ruler over the people Israel?
Well, Saul is not looking for this.
He's just trying to find some donkeys and he can't find him,
and he's ready to go home.
And then the servant says, let's go find this man of God.
He is like, we don't have any bread to give him.
And he's making excuses why God shouldn't use him.
And that's what he does to Samuel.
He is like, I'm from the time of Benjamin.
I'm from the least of the people of the tribe of Benjamin.
But see, you can't make excuses.
If God wants to use you.
God has bigger plans
and our excuses are moot when God has bigger plans.
And just as he turns to leave Samuel, look at
what the text says.
And never forget this verse, verse nine,
when he turned his back to leave Samuel,
God gave him another
heart, a new heart.
The condition of your heart is an enormous factor
for God to do his work.
A pure heart, a trusting heart, a humble heart,
a grateful heart, a forgiving heart.
These are the heart conditions that only God can give.
And God gave him a new heart.
And you're saying, well, I want a new heart.
How's a guy get a new heart like that?
Well, how does a guy go from being somebody who's not
that good of a shepherd, someone who kind
of hides re from responsibility, someone who shows a, a,
a general malaise and an aptist.
How does they, how do you go from that to someone
who God can trust to lead and protect his chosen people?
Well, here is precisely how it happens.
Verse six, then the spirit of the Lord will rush on you
and you will prophesy with them
and be turned into another man.
So God gives you a new heart because of your new heart.
Now you're a new person.
God changes the hearts of people
through the power of the Holy Spirit.
One of our core values is desperate
dependence on the Holy Spirit.
And listen to all the ways that the Holy Spirit is able
to make you into a new person.
In John 16, the Holy Spirit serves as the divine instructor
and guide you into the truth.
In one John two, the Holy Spirit anoints you
and teaches you about all things.
In John 14, the Holy Spirit teaches you all things
and reminds you of everything Jesus has told you.
And in Acts 10, the Holy Spirit speaks to you
and directs you the right way.
And in two Corinthians three, in one Peter three 18,
the Holy Spirit, by the way,
before I wanna read this, I'm gonna say something, okay?
Uh, one of my jobs is try
to turn this into a disciple making culture.
And I've encouraged many of you to take on the role
of a mentor and, uh, maybe, um, micro group leader
or maybe a CG leader.
And you know, the number one excuse,
and this isn't just Henderson Hills,
the number one excuse in all
of Christianity is like, I'm just not ready.
I'm just not prepared.
And I just wanna say, I agree with you 100%, neither am I,
because it is the Holy Spirit that produces life
and is able to make you competent to minister.
It's his work, not my work. It's his work, not your work.
And then Samuel gives Saul this newly anointed king,
a series of signs that will serve to confirm that
what he's saying is true.
You'll meet two men
and they'll tell you the lost donkeys have been found.
You'll meet three men, they'll have three goats
and three loaves of bread and the
skin of wine, and you're out of bread.
And they'll offer your bread and you'll take it.
And then there will be prophets
and they'll be carrying various musical instruments.
And the power of the Holy Spirit will come on you, Saul,
and you will prophesy as if you were one of the prophets.
And suddenly, Saul finds himself caught up in his new role
with a new, a new man, with a new heart, with a new power.
And despite his doubts, God is at work in Saul changing him.
And now we have a new king.
And later Samuel calls the people together
to introduce the king.
It's at mitzvah. Lots
of important things have happened in mitzvah,
and this is no different.
Samuel reminds them, by the way, that by asking for a king,
you're essentially rejecting God as your king,
but they still wanted a king.
And so they held a lottery for a king.
This is an election year.
I'm not suggesting anything different,
but Saul is chosen by lot,
but he's so anxious.
And by the way, let's give Saul a break here for a minute.
When you first read this, you think, you know what,
what a milk toast.
But Saul, I mean, but Samuel has said you don't want a king.
And they're like, yes, we do. And he is like,
he's gonna take everything you have your son's,
your daughters, your money or whatever, and
and there's like, Hey, Saul, you get to be that king.
I'm gonna hide in the luggage too, right?
That's not what happens when, when they identify
that it's Saul and he's hidden among the leg l luggage.
He's already been anointed as king,
and he's already been confirmed through these signs.
And he should have been confident in
God after his anointing.
But, but he looks fearful and insecure.
And when I say, I need you to be a mentor,
or I need you to find a mentor,
or I need you to be involved in a micro group, you are like,
eh, sounds a little too and fill in the blank.
I don't really care what the excuse is. Okay?
We are the exact same way.
We, we sometimes take a step back
and say, I don't think God could use me just like Saul did.
But God gave him a new heart.
God made him a new person, and God made him a new king.
And when the people saw him, they were thrilled
and they shouted, long live the king.
And despite this amazing moments, moments,
this is not your typical royal royal coronation.
And I think that some of Saul's reluctance
and some of his, maybe even spiritual ineptness
is a sign of struggles ahead.
But for now, Israel has their king.
Well, what I want us to do now is they're gonna change the
sermon from, from the text through the application.
And so, uh, this isn't just a history
of Israel's new king Saul.
This isn't just an introduction into the mon monarchy, okay?
This is not about Saul or Samuel or even Israel.
This is a story first and foremost about God.
And that's what we should do when we read the scripture, not
as about what does this say about me,
but what does this say about God?
And I promised you when we started that if you would listen
for 25 minutes,
that God would absolutely change your perspective,
that you would be renewed in your mind.
And the first thing I want you
to know is about God's subtle ways.
God's ways are very subtle. Ask Gideon, he wasn't in this.
He wasn't in that. He was in the what?
The still small voice.
God can often be very low key and gentle,
but he's the guiding hand be behind everything
that happens in these two chapters.
Saul's mission to find the donkeys is not
about lost donkeys.
It's about the very hand of God leading Saul to Samuel.
And so Saul, do you think you might be chasing lost donkeys?
No. It's God preparing you for something else.
So I just wanna say, Phil
and anyone listening to Phil today,
do you think you might be chasing lost donkeys?
No. This might be God preparing you for something else.
You're not just going through the up motions.
You can, you can find fulfillment
and meaning during your own donkey search.
In fact, today at lunch, uh,
this would be a great opportunity to say, Hey, what, what,
what's your lost donkey deal?
And to have a conversation as to
what God might be doing because he's subtle.
And it is in the, uh, con, it is within the confines
of a relational community that people are able to say, well,
I think this is what God might be doing in your life.
Why? Because number two, God is at work in the world.
He is still at work in the world today.
And sometimes it's difficult for us to see this
or believe this when we're sitting in the line waiting
for our kids or when we're sitting at the left turn, no,
no left turn lines when we're
sitting to trying to make a left turn.
It's just not happening. What are you gonna do?
You can just sit there and go, yeah, you can do that.
Or you can use this as an opportunity to say,
what is God trying to teach me?
What if for the rest of the school year you prayed
for your kids while you were sitting on waiting for them,
what, instead of sitting there, where are they?
I told them to meet me right here.
And they're just like, there's, I'm just kidding.
Don't, don't, don't waste that opportunity.
What's your lost donkey story?
Because God is still, he's still at work in the world
and his work is not finished.
And he loves involving those who he loves
to accomplish his work.
And he, Saul is teaching us.
He can choose anyone he wants to progress his plan.
You're not just wasting space.
You can be involved in God's work
and what you're doing for God matters.
And I need you to look for surprising appointments.
That's number three, God surprising appointments.
Remember when the unnamed servant insisted
that they find the man of God?
And Saul said, we don't have anything to give him.
And and he seemed to be avoiding the meeting,
but it was in this meeting that was orchestrated by God.
Remember the day before God said to Samuel,
I'm sending somebody, I'm Vegemite to meet you.
God will bring people to you
to help equip you for his service.
Sometimes in a community group, sometimes in a micro group,
sometimes in mentorship,
sometimes walking down the street, God can do that.
And then lastly, I want you to see
that God's spirit is changing lives.
The Holy Spirit is changing lives.
Saul serves as an example for us.
I wanna give you a new heart
and I wanna make you a new person.
And God's gift to Saul was change.
He was transformed by the Holy Spirit, able now to lead
and to be strong and battle against the Philistines,
to hear the word of God
and to follow the instructions from God's prophet Samuel.
God changes lives through the ministry of the Holy Spirit,
turning Saul into a different person.
God uses circumstances
and people to accomplish his purposes in the work
and in the lives of people, and transforms them.
He changed them. He makes them ready for his service,
sometimes subtly.
But God is at work in the lives of people.
Is he changing you this morning?
Don't be duped into thinking.
I'm just going through the motions.
You don't have to ask yourself what's the point?
We know the point.
Or this little boy who grew up in Western
Oklahoma, his name is Brad.
And Brad Clay used his love for the outdoors
and his love for Jesus to minister
to the students in his church.
And the dads couldn't stay away.
And so the dads started being involved,
and it went from a student ministry thing now
to an entire church thing,
and he called it Final Descent Outdoors.
It's a ministry which was born inside
of a little boy searching for donkeys.
Okay? I made that part up into a national television show,
which is in 40 million homes in North America.
And Brad will be our keynote speaker on Thursday night at
the men's ministry tailgate at 6:00 PM
You should plan to be there.
You see, this is an example of the work of God and church.
Hear me. God is at work that Jesus' death
and resurrection, they display God's plan for the world,
and his kingdom has arrived.
And the new king who lived a life, died his death
and resurrected on our behalf, wants us to be
involved in his ministry.
The Lord Jesus is our king.
And the gospel says, believe and trust and repent
and submit to King Jesus,
because those who submit to him will live
for him for eternity.
And God's mission declares that Jesus who died
and rose again in order to save us, will help us
and through us set the world, right?
Let's join Him in this mission. Let's pray.
Father, we thank you so much
that you give us examples like this all
through the Old Testament of people who are not prepared
to do something great for you, but you use them anyway,
and you change them through the power of the Holy Spirit.
I pray, Lord, that through these songs
and through these prayers
and through our willingness to submit and repent,
and to fall in line with what you want for us,
that lives will be changed
starting this morning for your glory.
In Jesus' name, amen.